[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi six mètres est
heureux de vous retrouver pour le début
de cette semaine d'information locale
sur tv 60,18 voici les titres de ce
journal c'est l'un des cinq piliers de
l'islam le ramadan a débuté ce lundi
pendant ce mois de jeûne les fidèles
sont invités à s'abstenir de boire de
manger et d'avoir des relations
sexuelles de l'aube au coucher du soleil
elle nous en parlons avec abdelaziz el
jaouhari co président du centre d'études
et d'initiatives musulmane des yvelines
est la première biennale d'architecturé
du paysage s'est ouverte vendredi à
versailles des expositions et
manifestations vont animer l'événement
jusqu'au 13 juillet dans plusieurs lieux
de la ville est notamment le potager du
roi qui ouvrait ses portes au public ce
week-end et puis elle souhaite alerter
sur le dérèglement climatique
l'association papier forêts organise
dimanche prochain un débat public à
fontenay le fleury l'objectif connaître
les engagements des candidats heureuse
européenne en matière d'écologie
le scrutin est fixée au 26 mai les
d'ailleurs pour parler de cette
thématique françois du lac est avec moi
en plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
chercheur au lsce c'est le laboratoire
des sciences du climat et de
l'environnement membre de papier forêt
qui organise donc c'est à cette soirée
débat public qui se déroulent et
dimanche prochains à l'espace voltaire
de fontenay le fleury on va en parler
dans un instant avant de présenter cette
soirée une petite réaction sur ce
rapport françois du lac publié
aujourd'hui par les scientifiques de l
ip et b e s sur l'état mondial est de
l'adieu divers la biodiversité pardon et
des écosystèmes
c'est alarmant un million d'espèces sur
les 8 millions qui existe sur terre
serait en danger en voie d'extinction
quel est l'intérêt de l'initiative de ce
rapport si vous voulez la biodiversité
aujourd'hui on considère que c'est un
marqueur de la bonne santé des
écosystèmes et de l'environnement et on
avait mais déjà depuis plus de 25 ans
travaillé beaucoup sur le changement
climatique tout en négligeant un petit
peu ce type de travail sur la
biodiversité donc cette plate forme
intergouvernementale qui à la fois
scientifiques et politiques sous l'égide
des nations unies a décidé finalement de
faire un état des lieux des
connaissances comme le giec le fait sur
le climat mais sur l'état
la biodiversité et on parle du coup la
ddt de biodiversité quels sont les liens
qui existent entre cette biodiversité en
péril et le changement climatique
alors la biodiversité a été très impacté
par le changement climatique vous avez d
un certain nombre d'espèces qui peuvent
pas suivre les variations de
températures et de précipitations
vous avez des endroits où les
écosystèmes sont fermées par exemple
dans le bassin méditerranéen si vous ne
chauffez trop la température de l'eau
vous avez des espèces qui peuvent pas
migrer et qui sont en train de
disparaître des éponges ou des algues ou
des coraux et donc on a aussi finalement
en jouant sur la biodiversité des
impacts des rétroactions sur le climat
par exemple en changeant la nature des
sols en remplaçant les forêts par des
soldes ou des sols cultivés on joue sur
le pouvoir de réflexion de l'énergie
solaire par la surface et donc on a des
effets de rétroaction sur la température
constat alarmant sur la biodiversité
vous étiez venu déjà sur ce plateau
parler aussi du constat alarmant pour le
climat c'est le cas aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait ce conte ce que nous dit
ce rapport qui est sorti aujourd'hui
donc j'ai pas encore eu le temps d'un
cliché mais en gros
nature est en train d'être impactée très
sévèrement on voit des disparitions
d'espèces à des taux qu'on n'a jamais
vue dans l'histoire humaine ces taux de
disparition s'accélère et ce groupe de
l'ipb es s'intéresse également aux
services rendus par la nature aux
sociétés humaines et donc on met en
danger un certain nombre de sociétés
humaines par la disparition de cette
biodiversité
alors si on vient à cette forêt qui est
organisé par papier forêt pour
interpeller justement les candidats aux
européennes sur l'urgence climatique
pourquoi il faut les les interpeller
aujourd'hui ces candidats si vous voulez
le ce que ce qu'on constate les
scientifiques depuis un certain temps
c'est que les signaux sont au rouge et
que on n'est toujours pas sur la bonne
trajectoire pour nous éviter des
réchauffements qui vont être
probablement catastrophique pour la
biodiversité mais aussi pour les
sociétés humaines et donc on a pensé que
c'était important de profiter de cette
occasion des élections européennes pour
parler de ce sujet là l'europe et dans
une europe des 28 c'est le troisième
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre au
monde et c'est aussi un des moteurs en
termes de normalisation des accords
internationaux des normes
environnementales donc il est important
que l'europe prenne le leadership un
moment où les états unis se sont
complètement retirés de la cote 21 et
comment l'europe peut agir justement
parlement européen sur certains cette
urgence climatique
comment il peut agir alors si vous
voulez il ya une initiative qui a été
proposé et que la notre association
soutient par une association qui
s'appelle agir pour le climat qui est de
créer un nouveau traité européen que les
gouvernements pourraient faire entériner
et qui mettrait finalement l'objectif de
la transition climatique et pour la
biodiversité au centre des
préoccupations européennes avec la
création d'une banque destinée à émettre
de l'argent non pas pour relancer
l'économie comme on le fait déjà depuis
quelques années mais vraiment pour en
faire prendre toutes les mesures qu'il
faut prendre pour remédier à ce
changement climatique quand vous écoutez
ce que disent les candidats aujourd'hui
ce que cette thématique vous avez
l'impression que cette thématique du
climat est assez pris en compte est ce
qu'elle est présente dans le dans le
débat les débats de cette campagne aux
européennes
alors si vous voulez c'est une
thématique qui relativement présente
mais c'est pas nouveau
elle est d'autant plus présente que la
société civile fait pression il ya des
marches pour le climat régulièrement
mais quand on regarde sur la dernière
mandature par exemple les textes qui ont
été les propositions de lois qui ont été
votées par tous ces partis on s'aperçoit
qu'entre les discours et ce qui est fait
en réalité il ya souvent des décalages
et puis on a aussi maintenant une
tendance à mettre ce point en avant dans
tous les programmes et donc on a essayé
d'avoir un maximum de listes pour
comprendre vraiment quelles étaient
leurs différences alors justement
quelles listes ont répondu présentes à
votre invitation qui allie seront
présentes dimanche
alors on a contacté les treize listes
qui avaient annoncé leur liste assez tôt
pour pouvoir être présentes dont sept
ont répondu aujourd'hui on espère encore
des réponses de 2,3 supplémentaires ça
va ça couvre tout l'échiquier on va du
rassemblement national au parti
communiste en passant par lui dit le ps
les verts
debout la france également et puis tous
dans la plupart de ces listes on aura
des vraiment des candidats en bonne
position sur sur les listes électorales
de l'europe et des gens qui sont
vraiment sur la thématique
environnementale mais on précise justin
qui a une trentaine de listes qui sont
candidates en tout pour ces élections
européennes
un mot pour terminer sur papier fort et
quelques mots de présentation sur cette
association qui organise cette forêt oui
ben merci de même invité de me donner
l'occasion d'en parler c'est une
association qui a été créée en 91 donc a
déjà une existence on a été créé au
départ pour pousser à recyclage du
papier et en fait on s'est donné une
mission d'éducation à l'environnement et
au climat
c'est une association qui a porté deux
festivals alternatiba sur versailles
grand parc et donc on intervient
principalement sur le périmètre autour
de versailles et de saint quentin en
yvelines et on fait tous les ans pour le
printemps festival qu'on appelle le
printemps de l'environnement sur lequel
on aborde un thème qui change chaque
année et on reçoit les scolaires là on a
reçu par exemple cette année 650 élèves
des écoles de fontenay et puis on a une
expo qui est ouverte au grand public
également
merci françois du lac est chercheur au
lsce vous êtes membre de l'association
papier forêt sortir du de l'impasse du
dérèglement climatique et grâce à
l'europe débat public a retrouvé ce
dimanche à l'espace voltaire de
fontenay-le-fleury c'est à partir de
18h30 et l'inscription est à faire sur
le lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
dans l'actualité c'est une première
édition à versailles le coup d'envoi de
la bap la biennale d'architecturé de
paysage de l'île de france a été donné
vendredi dernier à versailles pour
l'occasion présence de nicolas sarkozy
de la présidente de la région ile de
france valérie pécresse et du maire de
versailles françois de mazières jusqu'au
13 juillet plusieurs lieux de la ville
vont accueillir et des expositions
encore des manifestations ce week-end
c'est le potager du roi qui ouvrait ses
portes au public le reportage
d'oreillons ce très joli inciterait
grain 9 hectares de fruits de légumes ou
encore d'herbes aromatiques
situé en plein coeur du centre
historique de versailles le potager du
roi a été construit par jean baptiste de
la quintinie à la demande du roi louis
xiv qui était féru de jardinage
il est classé monument historique et
jardins
remarquable j'imaginais pas que ce soit
aussi grand c'est assez respectueux je
trouve ça garder quand même l'esprit
naturel et puis bah on va c'est sympa
qui est des petits bord du petit chef
c'est un lieu que j'aime bien où je
viens parfois acheter des légumes parce
qu'ils produisent aussi des légumes
et puis c'est quand même nos ancêtres
qui ont mis ce potager au point
habituellement fermés au public ce lieu
confidentiel ouvre gratuitement ses
portes à l'occasion d' esprit jardin
cette année le potager du roi fait
également partie de la programmation de
la première biennale d'architecturé de
paysage de versailles
l'idée c'est de mettre en valeur la
relation entre la ville et la production
alimentaire
la villa doit être pour exister
alimenter alimenter que ce soit en
produits alimentaires mais aussi en
idées en construction en énergie et donc
c'est ça quand on essaie de mettre en
valeur aujourd'hui ici avec le temps
capricieux vous n'avez pas pu tout
découvrir sur la production de ses
fruits et légumes qui firent la renommée
de la table du roi soleil
sachez que jusqu'à mi juillet plusieurs
visites sont organisées
on parlera un peu plus tard dans ce
journal du ramadan m'ont invité
abdelaziz el jaouhari qui doit encore
arriver
on en parlera d'ici la fin de ce journal
en tout cas en attendant il doit être
voté d'ici 2020 le rl pays règlement
local de publicité intercommunale est en
cours de rédaction par saint quentin en
yvelines
l'objectif affiché par l'agglomération
limiter l'impact de la publicité
extérieure et de la pollution visuelle
sur le territoire des douze communes des
grandes orientations ont été définies
elles ne vont pas assez loin d'après le
collectif champ libre qui regroupe une
quinzaine d'associations du territoire
champ libre demande une consultation
publique sur le sujet et établi des
préconisations pour le futur texte une
lettre ouverte en ce sens a été envoyée
le mois dernier à grégory gary astier
vice président de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de la stratégie
commerciale écouter ses propos
recueillis par mélanie poker pour nous
donc il va pas assez loin
principalement déjà sur les écrans
numériques publicitaires en les
interdisant pas sur l'ensemble des zones
il risque d'y avoir une une invasion de
d'écran sur sur saint quentin en
yvelines suite à suite à la la fin de la
rédaction de ce rlp y ça va pas assez
loin non plus sur l'extinction des
enseignes le soir on souhaiterait que ce
soit éteint dès la fermeture de des
commerces et pas uniquement à partir de
22 heures
et enfin il ya des ex ante des
exceptions un troisième exemple sur tout
ce qui est mobilier urbain il ya des
exceptions pour que ça reste allumée
toute la nuit
plutôt que plutôt que de les éteindre
quand on sait que la pollution lumineuse
est la deuxième cause de mortalité des
d'insectes après les pesticides
voilà on estime que ça va pas et c'est
vrai que c'est pas utile de dépenser non
plus aussi beaucoup d'énergie
d'électricité pour ce genre de choses là
lui est d'après le collectif
aucun retour à cette lettre n'a été fait
par saint quentin en yvelines contacté
par notre rédaction l'agglomération ne
souhaite pas pour le moment s'exprimer
sur le sujet est le sport avec ce
tournoi de padel ce week-end il
réunissait les meilleurs joueurs
français à l'invitation du club local
l'occasion pour le public de découvrir
cette discipline cousine du tennis venus
d'amérique du sud et d'espagne le sujet
doré lyons une raquette une balle et
quatre joueurs sur le terrain
voici les principaux ingrédients d'un
match de padel à mi chemin entre le
tennis et le squash ce sport ibérique se
pratique en salle pour ce tournoi p500
46 équipes se sont affrontées au paddle
club de bois d'arcy
il s'agit du seul établissement
yvelinois où l'on peut pratiquer ce
sport en a on a environ 300 à 400
joueurs réguliers par mois et qui
viennent
jouer au pad alloue au badminton et puis
voilà on a on a plus de 7000 joueurs qui
sont passés depuis l'ouverture
c'est très très bien pour le club mais
aussi pour le paddle en général qui ne
cesse de prendre
voilà c'est sportivement ludique et si
conviviale qui convient à tous
concernant les règles on compte les
points comme au tennis en deux sets
gagnants avec tout de même quelques
particularités au niveau du service on
va servir à la cuillère sas a pas un
service par an à la cuillère après
rebond
ce qui est important c'est que la balle
rebondisse toujours une forme
sur la moquette du camp adverse si on
envoie la balle au dessus du filet
qu'elles touchent directement le mur ses
fautes sport très populaire dans les
pays hispaniques le padel fait
aujourd'hui de plus en plus d'adeptes en
france c'est vachement plus ludique et
on peut vachement but s'amuser sans
forcément avoir un niveau de langue
devant moi j'ai pas un gros niveau de
tennis ni de padel d'ailleurs mais je
m'éclate à la clac à en faire je viens
au moins quatre fois par semaine
actuellement 5300 personnes font partie
du circuit français
le nombre de pratiquants dépasse quant à
lui les 50000 et du sport encore avec la
chronique hebdomadaire de michael et
demi d'euros bonsoir annonceurs grégory
vous nous présenter comme chaque lundi
les résultats du week-end on va pouvoir
le faire michael et on commence avec du
football le stade gilbert chant sac de
trappes peut exulter le est rap est
peut-être en train d'écrire l'une des
plus belles pages de son histoire les
trappistes de vega ni contre
aubergenville pour faire un grand pas
vers une montée en régionale 2 et ceux
qui l'ont fait grâce à deux buts en
première période masila itsm au standard
il a marqué sur ce corner locaux font
ensuite le break juste avant la mi temps
par car à quoi tu as 2 à 0 ce sera le
score final on écoute la réaction de
l'un des anciens de cette équipe
hamidou sissoko très bien très bien
bon un des derniers matches à domicile
on gagne 2 0 donc c'est très bien c'est
très bien pour la suite à deux matches
de la fin c'est ça sent bon ça sent bon
après cette victoire trappe occupe
désormais la première place du
classement à deux journées de la fin du
championnat
c'est le sprint final de match c'est pas
le moment de baisser les bras
surtout pas donc on va mobiliser nos
forces
rester concentré de ces êtres finir au
mieux qu'à avec deux victoires on monte
donc là on va essayer de finir
correctement
prochain match pour les trappistes le
dimanche 19 mai sur le terrain de rueil
malmaison
alors avant passer aux autres résultats
grégory je vous propose de regarder
cette séquence dans les vestiaires
à l'âge où on espère que ça se
concrétisera par une montée en fin de
saison a souffert il en reste deux
matches andy reste deux matches donc on
va suivre ça avec intérêt
on continue par du rugby michael une
équipe qui est déjà championne c'est ça
versailles toujours invaincu cette
saison après avoir terminé premier de la
poule en honneur et après avoir raflé un
titre de champion ile de france la
semaine dernière les hommes de la cité
royale ont toujours faim ils ont
remporté ce week-end leur 32e de finale
du championnat de france contre lille à
villeneuve
score final 27 à 0 ils rencontreront le
club de vesoul
le dimanche 19 mai en 16e de finale on
termine par du baseball
ça va mieux pour les cougars de monti le
bretonneux dans le championnat de
première division lésigny montain se
sont imposés deux fois ce week-end
contre les cavigal de nice hall lé score
19 à 5 pour le dans la première partie 6
à 3 dans le second match avec sept
victoires montigny le bretonneux
consolide sa deuxième place de la poule
b
merci michael on vous retrouve dans
votre émission hebdomadaire le 7-8 sport
c'est juste après ce journal d'autres
résultats et quelques annonce également
des prochains événements vous avez parlé
de gymnastique brizard en tout cas je
m'échauffais leur loge on va vous
laisser vous échauffer cette exposition
est d'abord qui se tient jusqu'au 27
juillet au musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines elle est consacrée
aux objets de notre vie quotidienne ces
objets qui sont et diversifiée depuis
l'émergence de la société de
consommation
après la seconde guerre mondiale près de
90 pièces composent cette collection
découvertes signé mélanie poké du
thermomix des années 70 robot de cuisine
de 2015
l'histoire de nos objets au musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines il
règne comme une atmosphère de madeleine
de proust
un désaveu
les objets emblématiques sens veut que
tout le monde connaît c'est la petite
balance terraillon on a ce petit
ce petit appareil qui en fait assez
innovant en matière de balance de
cuisine puisque l'ensemble du mécanisme
des cachets pour être enfermé dans une
boîte très design est très
très organique comme ça très très simple
avec les angles arrondis pour sa
nouvelle exposition le musée nous
entraîne dans l'histoire des objets de
notre temps une exposition penser de
manière thématique autour des tanks qui
rythment en foyer 7,4 à thématiques sont
l'espace de la cuisine l'hygiène les
nouvelles technologies et le confort et
à travers c'est
donc ces quatre entrées on propose une
série d'objets assez assez divers et qui
qui rendent compte en fait de la manière
dont l'espace domestique donc
l'habitation s'est progressivement dotés
d'un daim
collection d'objets et donc des objets
avec une valeur d usage des usages mais
aussi du design la collection vous même
des années 30 aux années 2010 avec une
période plus présente que les autres les
années 70 on voit arriver une explosion
de couleurs et de formes
c'est vrai que cette
et sort un peu matérialiste de d'objets
souvent sa compagne est d'obliger un
petit peu gadget
bon je pense par exemple au couteau
électrique c'est quelque chose qui était
très en vogue dans les années
soixante dix et qui est peut-être
aujourd'hui temblay un petit peu entendu
en désuétude près de 90 objets ont été
sélectionnées dans la collection du
musée
une occasion de partager entre
générations nos intérieurs et on revient
à présent à cette actualité du jour le
mois du ramadan a donc démarré à ce
lundi pourrait environ cent quarante
mille personnes de confession musulmane
dans les yvelines
il devrait s'achever le 4 ou le 5 juin
prochain pour en parler mon invité qui
est arrivé abdelaziz el jaouhari bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le vous êtes le
coprésident du cemi c'est le centre
d'études et d'initiatives musulmane des
yvelines c'est un observatoire de la
présence musulmane locale déjà une
première creed question qu'est ce qu'il
représente le ramadan pour les musulmans
premièrement c'est un des cinq piliers
de l'islam donc c'est vraiment une des
adorations fondamental pour la
communauté de croyants ajoutez à cela
donc s'est doublée d'un comment dire
d'un vrai travail de générosité pendant
ce mois
donc c'est un bois où nous le constatons
dans tous nos lieux de culte qui est un
regain de la pratique religieuse
donc il ya déjà le jeune en lui même
mais c'est aussi les deux espaces de
prière nos mosquées une salle de prière
connaissent une activité très intense ce
mois ci mais qu'est ce qu'il signifie
justement ce jeune pourquoi on pourrait
il ya ce jeune ça premièrement il ya une
dimension verticale j'allais dire donc
c'est un signe d'adoration mais à une
dimension horizontale parce que par
l'expérience de cette privation le
musulman c'est aussi l'expérience des
gens qui sont privés toute l'année et
non pas de manière volontaire mais parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens parce que
ils ont des difficultés donc c'est aussi
un moyen pour se rappeler cette réalité
et puis se rappeler son devoir vis-à-vis
des autres justement qui sont dans le
besoin qui sont nécessiteux on connaît
le jeune pour ce mois du ramadan mais
vous le disiez ce n'est pas que ça le
ramadan c'est aussi un moment de partage
c'est aussi le moment de se retrouver
avec ça avec sa famille quand on rompt
le jeûne d'exactement donc c
on soirée c'est vraiment des moments des
moments familiaux par excellence mais
c'est aussi des moments de partage au
delà de la famille avec le voisinage
aussi avec les personnes en difficulté
donc c'est à moi et d'ailleurs les
yvelines
notre département n'y échappe pas donc
les associations et même les familles
préparent et distribue énormément de
repas pendant ce mois sacré est à la
fois pour les personnes sans domicile
fixe mais aussi pour des familles qui
sont dans le besoin pour des réfugiés ou
tout simplement offre comme on dire des
repas ou des gâteaux voisins aux amis et
aux collègues et instituts et donc c'est
vraiment en effet à moi de partage par
excellence donc didier a aussi un moment
de recueillement à métaux grâce qui est
le président du conseil français du
culte musulman a demandé pour ce mois du
ramadan de penser à ceux qui n'ont pas
les moyens de rompre le jeûne aux femmes
isolées et aussi à ceux qui passent les
épreuves du baccalauréat
il ya aussi dépensé pendant ce ramadan
exactement donc c'est vraiment à moi on
a dépensé justement pour tous ceux qui
sont dans le besoin et dont la
difficulté de manière générale
indépendamment d'ailleurs de de leur
confession de l'eau qui soit porteur
d'une croyance ou pas vous avez les
associations musulmanes locales dans les
yvelines qui distribue quelques milliers
de repas par jour pendant ce mois du
ramadan donc en effet donc c'est
vraiment un moment et à moi très marqué
par cette pensée aux autres et par la
solidarité est ce que c'est un mois du
ramadan qui va être plus difficile pour
les musulmans sur une période où les
jours vont s'allonger jusqu'à la fin de
ce ramadan pas forcément pas forcément
les années précédentes c'était à peu
près la même chose mais c'est vrai que
bon les tout en sachant que les
l'acte du jeune ont sont exclus les
enfants les personnes âgées les
personnes malades les femmes enceintes
et ainsi de suite c'est vraiment que les
personnes qui sont en bonne santé qui
peuvent le supporter et qui peuvent le
faire mais toutes les personnes
comment dire souffrant ou très jeunes ne
sont pas du tout concerné par cette cet
acte d'adoration à la fin du ramadan est
prévue pour début juin quand et comment
sera soit fixé la date exacte de la fin
du ramadan en fait le mois du ramadan
comme tout le calendrier musulman c'est
un calendrier lunaire
donc c'est avec le l'apparition de la
nouvelle la naissance de la nouvelle
lune
bon c'est vrai que ça ne débat encore
qu'il reste dans la communauté musulmane
mais bon d'un point de vue scientifique
le débat il est tranchée depuis
longtemps parce que nous avons tous les
outils comment dire pour déterminer le
début la fin de tous les mois d'ailleurs
et pas que le mois du ramadan ceci dit
un débat
théologique intense au sein de la
communauté sur le sujet parce que vous
avez des écoles de pensée qui persistent
sur la notion de la vue à l'oeil nu de
la naissance de la lune mais bon les
choses vont aller je pense vont
s'équilibrer d'ici deux prochaines
années n'en revenons au sémillant vous
avez un rôle on l'a dit d'observatoire
dans les yvelines alors vous dénombré
140 mille personnes environ de
confession musulmane dans le département
soit 10% de la population
quel est votre rôle alors pendant 7 à du
ramadan vous disiez il ya ce rôle de
distribution des repas d'accompagnement
le rôle du cemi quel est il
en fait on travaille justement sur la
présence musulmane au sein des yvelines
est tout simplement deux à la fois
d'avoir une comment dire deux des
données qui soient fiables
je pense que c'est important et pour la
communauté musulmane mais pour tous nos
partenaires publics ou privés d'ailleurs
et pour la communauté elle-même et
deuxièmement c'est qu'il ya un certain
nombre de deux comment dire de besoin et
qu'il faut remonter donc ça peut être
sur la question des lieux de culte ça
peut être sur les carrés confessionnels
dans les cimetières
ça peut être sur les besoins de
solidarité ou n'en a parlé donc voilà
donc c'est vraiment de se doter dans
ceux d'un certain nombre de deux relevés
de terrain pour accompagner au mieux et
dont la sérénité la communauté mais
aussi et pas que la communauté c'est nos
partenaires publics privés
les autres communautés religieuses et
dans les vignes aussi le cimic elle
conseille des institutions musulmanes
des civils vous en faisiez partie je
crois votre départ
pourquoi avoir créé du coup leucémie ce
qu'elles sont c'est joli les objectifs
est ce que c'est un concurrent ou sont
deux pas du tout deux organismes
complémentaires finalement du tout parce
que leucémie n'est pas du tout sur la
dimension de la représentation
donc nous le pensons que c'est
d'ailleurs même au début du s'immiscer
telle approche
c'était une approche un peu pied jantes
de rentrer dans cette question de la
représentation parce qu'après ça fige
les choses et on n'est plus dans des
dons déroule que voilà que dans un
travail effectif
mais par contre c'est des structures qui
peuvent être complémentaires nettement
complémentaires puisque les champs
d'action sont complètement différents
merci d aziz el haouari je rappelle que
vous êtes le coprésident du cemi c'est
le centre d'études et d'initiatives
musulmane d une merci d'être reversé à
vous parler de ce début du ramadan sur
notre plateau c'est la fin de ce journal
le replay a consultés sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile et
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver dès
demain pour une nouvelle édition belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]